what if marrow M1 Isaac netro dies the
palace Invasion fails 5 000 Mighty
Chimera and hybrid cocoons hatch and
standing in their way of world
domination are the Phantom troop
karapika the zoldik family and the full
might of the hunter Association do any
of them have a chance or is this world
completely doomed let's find out here's
the situation to make this Regal insect
hypothesis work we just need to remove
one factor from the world which is that
the poor man's Rose will not contain
poison natural will die and blow marowam
to bits like soap after which point he
will reform thanks to his Royal gaunts
but no poison so he won't die which
means we're already in a lot of trouble
because now we're dealing with post Rose
marowam who is somehow infinitely more
powerful than even pre-rose but other
changes include both poof and up
Surviving the invasion albeit in a
somewhat diminished state but also
comiki survives which is simply
delightful anyone else who died during
the palace invasion is still going to
die mostly meaning characters like Chito
but also Pito is going to die after
being obliterated by gone which taking
up small form into account leaves us
with one functional royal guard in
shirepoof however marowam came to two
important conclusions during the palace
Invasion one is that he decided that
deserving humans would be allowed to
live in his new ant-based Society
meanwhile some less deserving humans
will be granted a special preserve over
there is a nice place to live however a
lot of humans will still be used for
food we can't get around that ants gotta
eat in the series right before his death
marrowham actually reconsiders the whole
world domination plan altogether but our
hypothetical meruem never quite reaches
that morality Clarity so going forward
marowam has three key missions one
identify the special humans that will be
given the antequivalent of diplomatic
immunity in the New World Order 2. find
a suitable location for the permanent
human reserve and finally complete and
total world domination also this video
is sponsored by World of Warships the
free-to-play naval Warfare multiplayer
online game with new content released
every month new ships in-game Nations
fun cosmetics and even new ship classes
you can always count on a nice fresh
gameplay experience in one of the
stunning 12v12 Arenas with 10 new ships
from Central and South America being put
into the game this month with all sorts
of other crazy Shenanigans ranging from
Godzilla to Transformers to waifus with
the azulane collaboration World of
Warships has amazing Graphics across 40
unique maps with Dynamic weather
conditions and ridiculously amazing
water effects crafting an immersive
Naval experience with many multiple
ships to choose from including
battleships destroyers aircraft carriers
Cruisers and submarines submarines I
believe are referred to as boats rather
than ships despite the fact they are
technically ships Naval Warfare makes no
sense but it's still really cool but
what does make sense is to use code
Bravo to receive a huge starter pack
including a bunch of doubloons credits
premium account time and a ship or a
boat if it's a submarine so go do that
thing but pronounce back to you me and
total world domination and the first
step towards all three of these fun
things is to complete the Sorting
process that was put on pause because
the original no plan was to sort almost
5 million citizens of this quarter which
would have resulted in an estimated 50
000 nen using Chimera and hybrids in the
series we only got to 5 000 before that
was stopped but marowen was going to see
this process through and assemble his
full Army of 50 000. yes he has
recognized that humans should be allowed
to live in some sort of limited capacity
but his cold and logical side is going
to do what is necessary to consolidate
power before enacting his Ideal World I
mean as the king said himself at first
he will use Terror to rule but then once
he has control it's onwards to some sort
of insect Utopia I mean in his own words
I'll create a world so fair that the
very concept of inequality will be
forgotten but then again what exactly
does merom deem as fair to begin in
terms of geography escorto is located in
the bottom left of the hunter hunter
world map meaning that marowam's first
logical push is going to be further into
the orbian continent and this is a
massive first move because we
immediately collide with some very well
known locations and people fun fact the
vast majority of to Hunter takes place
on and around the European continent
with the first major Collision coming in
the form of meteor City and tagashi is
never explicitly stated where meteor
city is however it's almost certainly on
your beer and quite close to escort too
if you want to know why go and check out
the crawler oito sibling video because
that goes into far more detail about all
the context clues but we we do not have
time for that we we have a world to
dominate and meruem is going to see
little to no value in meteor City Beyond
delicious actually not so delicious food
but but I guess it's food and this will
trigger a conflict with the Phantom
troop they will likely be absent as the
antarmy Swarms the city but they will
almost certainly attempt to enact some
sort of Vengeance or Requiem in response
basic and soldiers in fact even the
hibernate then uses they are nothing
compared to the troop individually that
is against an army of 50 000 nen users
will look even the Phantom Trooper did
the pretty screwed the best case
scenario for them is to flee and have
crawler come up with some sort of plan
to move forward which could take literal
years considering how he needed a full
year to plan and collect the abilities
just to defeat hiso if the troop do
anything less then they're dead they're
just dead they'll take lots of ants with
them to dead place but it's just far too
overwhelming however there is also a
pretty decent chance that marowen will
recognize the troop members as special
humans crolo at the very least and I
wouldn't see it as Beyond them at all to
join and society and buy their time from
here maroum is going to be much more
tactful because taking a city that
absolutely no one cares about by force
is one thing but the next big Target on
yorubia is York new city which is a
major city within a V5 Nation called the
United States of Sahara I mean yes he
could just March in and take the city in
fact he could probably March in and take
the whole country but that's far from
the most efficient way to do things I
think it's much more likely that marowen
will have his aunts infiltrate positions
of power kind of like how Pito was
puppeteering the dictator in his court
toe to make it seem like ah everything's
running as usual which wasn't good the
eastgato did not run well but at the
very least it kept up public appearances
it wasn't running worse than normal
problem though because Pito is of course
dead but with 50 000 men using ANS look
a couple of them are gonna be
manipulators so it's not going to be a
problem stuff like ikalgo's Living Dead
Dolls but also shireproof could use his
cocoon and just keep rolling the
diceland inabilities if somehow there is
nothing suitable of the 50 000 ants so
maroum is going to conduct a secret
invasion of this country because risking
open Warfare would be ridiculous all it
does is destroy all of the resources you
need the resources in this case probably
being people and by the time characters
like karapika begin to notice it's going
to be too late and speaking of there is
nothing that karapika will be able to do
on his own nor would he necessarily make
it a priority to fight off an Ant
Invasion because at this point
karapika's only goal in life is to
recover the Scarlet eyes also he's smart
enough to very quickly do all of the nen
mats and figure out that humanity is
well it's pretty doomed I wouldn't put
it past karapika to attempt to join
marowam on the condition of recovering
his Clan's eyes to which marowen will
probably be very very confused he goes
to him that's kind of like listening to
a cow wanting to recover the milk from
its herd currently being sold in
supermarkets the karapika is also on the
level of special humans I think that
marowam would recognize him both in
terms of intellect and power because if
karapika isn't worthy then no one has a
chance whale island is going to fall
victim shortly after though because it's
estimated to exist somewhere off the
coast of Europe which was worked out by
absolute Heroes on the internet with
just far too much time on their hands
but I really appreciate their work and
of course their sweet fa that whale
Island can do to save itself so and at a
certain point marowen will have assumed
control of the entire European continent
which is important because that will
dissuade the other V5 Nations now
probably known as the V4 from declaring
open War as marowam now has the military
might Equitable to any of their Nations
significantly more due to the then using
ants but speaking off assuming that
marowam only sorted an estimated one
percent of the Continental population
then that would still result in the
birth of 5 million new hybrid and
soldiers now I don't think that meruem
necessarily needs to do this but it's
important to note that he can at any
given point he can snap his auntie
fingers fingers mandible no those are
the face things I don't know enough
about ants doesn't matter he'll do some
sort of snapping motion and then bam
five million more then using ants if he
wants the only real restriction on
numbers is thinking about feeding them I
mean let's say each Chimera ant needs
one human a day well then you're burning
through five million humans a day and
that is simply unsustainable so with
that in mind I think the number is
likely to stay around 50 to 100 000
soldiers which is still a lot like a lot
a lot and with this newfound power merom
can afford to be a bit more public as he
sets his sights on the next continent
which has no name but I refer to as not
South America because it is just South
America but upside down nobody ever
accused tagashi of being particularly
original when it comes to World building
I mean part of this continent is also
the nation of Japan and I wonder what
that's a reference to but this consonant
as a whole is best known for being the
site of the 287th hunter exam and a
grand total of nothing else there is a
V5 Nation here the kukanu king but we
know nothing else so maroum is going to
steamroll his way through not South
America but very very politely and as
non-destructively as possible and after
this we move on to something very very
exciting going upwards Maryland's next
Target is the continent of not Africa
which I've named for what I hope are
clear reasons and this contains three
major and I mean major serious hotspots
the first of which is kukuru Mountain
the home of the zoldic family the zoldx
will not engage because they are not
Heroes the zodics are businessmen Xeno
in particular has experienced the power
of the ant king and so would be highly
unlikely to take a job assassinating him
even if a contract was offered however
the zodics would absolutely be deemed as
special humans by maroum and the King
may even use his ridiculous resources to
hire them for his purposes again they're
a family business so they're going to go
wherever the economic waves decide to
take them given that meruem is now the
single richest being on the planet with
two continents worth of cash in his
aunt's Dash from here on out he will
always be the highest paying client
meanwhile on the other side of North
Africa is Heaven's Arena which holds a
great opportunity for Maryland let's be
real at this point the silent invasion
is well and truly done people all over
the world now know about the ants
primarily because the ants now consist
of half the world so to break the
remaining countries mentally maraware
may very well participate in Heaven's
Arena fighting his way to the top in
televised matches just to prove that he
is the strongest being alive because as
far as the general public is concerned
Heaven's arena is home to the most
powerful of the humans and marowam
conquering that whilst requiring no
effort on his part would be a huge
psychological blow to humanity speaking
of blow and tahisoka having heard tell
of this all-powerful ant king there is
no way that Mr battleclan himself could
resist a challenge and he just so
happens to be a floor master of Heaven's
Arena meaning that on his way to
domination marowen will indeed have to
fight hisoka and it's going to go about
as well as you think which is really
really well for marowam and not very
well for hisoka who will almost
certainly die unless merom sees
something special within him however I
think that marawan will mostly just
speak confused and perplexed by hisoka's
constant sexual arouse and then it's
time for the big one so adani city is
also located in North Africa which we
know again thanks to those wonderful
internet Heroes but this is very
important because that's where the
hunter Association headquarters are
located let's put this into some
perspective marrow M now has a standing
army of nen users who likely number in
the hundreds of thousands meanwhile the
hunter Association has just under 700
licensed Hunters so I wonder how this is
going to go at this point I believe that
the association would take on a more
diplomatic role depending on who becomes
the chairman after Network for example
if it's cheetah then she will look to
facilitate marowam's world domination
with as few human casualties as possible
however if pariston was the chairman
then I suspect he would do the same but
have a lot more fun with it and by fun I
mean be a general prick wherever
possible because you know in this
scenario I don't think it's a given that
pariston resigns from his position as
chairman there's just far too much fun
to be had many of the hunters are likely
to be considered recognized under
marowam's designation of worthy human
certainly The Zodiacs but most of all
being one Jing freaks here's a bit of a
wild card here but like krapika he's
smart enough to sense that the times are
changing and of all of the humans Jing
feels the most adaptable and he would
certainly thrive in Ant World with the
hunter Association on board wild
Conquest becomes a lot more simple the
remaining two V5 nations would just sit
down at this point and probably
negotiate surrender terms one of them
being located on not Australia which
looks like a real good place to set up
some sort of human preserve large enough
to hold Millions but segregated enough
from the rest of Ant World the name of
the country here is or I suppose was the
beggarosa union doesn't matter anymore
what matters is that on the way to not
Australia the Chimera ants will discover
Greed Island the one and only territory
in this world that maroum is incapable
of taking by force because due to the
Restriction of the mechanics of the
island Razer and any of the dev team can
just continuously evict them so funnily
enough marowen will be forced to play
Greed Island although to be fair marowen
does like games so this is just going to
be another fun curiosity the only
problem being how he will eventually
acquire plot of beach because he will
need to form a team to play dodgeball
against Razer but in this case marowam
simply uses his extreme wealth and
connections to acquire as many copies of
Greed Island as possible and then
inserts enough soldiers to make a team
dodgeball does not go well for Razer in
fact he almost certainly dies then
marowen completes the quiz because he
has a very good memory wins the game and
becomes the Island's new Overlord now at
this point there is only one consonant
and one country that is not surrendered
which is Asia home to the kakin Empire
whose strongest fighting force are
Prince Benjamin's Nan Army and the three
mafia families and as fascinating as
they are during the succession War which
now never happens there is absolutely
nothing they can do to stop marowen
what's more interesting here is that
maroware may encounter Beyond's netra
who is definitely a special human
considering that he is the son of Isaac
naturo merum's most respected of all of
the humans and if he isn't aware already
then beyond will inform marowam about
the dark constant seeing the King as a
fantastic and at this point literally
the only vehicle to get there marowam
could know about the continent already
through Jing or paristan but it's only
at this point that the knowledge is
definite and this takes us to one of my
all-time favorite Miriam quotes if this
is the Mandate of Heaven that I've been
given I fear nothing except the tedium
it will bring and having flawlessly
beaten the tutorial level that is the
human realm marowen will then set out to
complete the main game a homecoming of
sorts as he makes it his mission to
conquer the Dark Continent